hey guys Pete here today I'm going to do
a preview of yellowjacket season 2
episode 7 which is titled burial they
finally released a teaser trailer there
are a ton of promo photos to look
through and also a full clip that is
pretty crazy if any of that sounds like
spoilers then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it the descriptions for this
season's episodes just sort of keep
getting crazier this one for 207 reads
Sometimes the best therapy is cranking
the hits to 11. So today we're exploring
the hardcore kid care Revival movement
11 o'clock theatrical birdcore numbers
some late hits of the renovation wave
era call us about a spin-off HGTV flower
Duets and a classic live record out in
the wilderness coach Scott does a great
Carl Havoc impression for an unimpressed
Misti there are only a couple of things
that I'll mention because a lot of this
sound sounds like it's in the voice of a
joke I'm not in on birdcore definitely
makes me think of Misty though and in
the trailer there is this exciting shot
of her coming out of a sensory
deprivation tank at night I imagine
she'll go on a little trip while she's
in there and we'll finally get to see
what that Twin Peaks imagery in the
opening credits is all about and how the
human actor they cast as Caligula fits
into things in a lot of ways Misty is
the yellow jacket that seems to be the
least likely to hallucinate so I think
this will be awesome the Classic live
record reference is probably connected
to the song we hear in the MTV clip
which for my money is one of the most
annoying pop songs of the era no offense
intended if you dig it but this was one
of those songs that had jingle Vibes
because it would get stuck in your head
despite the fact that you didn't like it
and it was so popular that if you went
anywhere in the mid 90s there was a
chance it might infect your brain the
song Idol is Lightning Crashes and it's
by the band Live if you were wondering
what the adult yellow jackets were
starting to dance to at their reunion at
lottie's compound the Carl Havoc thing
is somewhat concerning the trailer ends
with a teary-eyed shot of Coach Ben out
in the wilderness my first impression
was that he might be at the poop bucket
spot because Misty's there and it looks
like they might be on the edge of that
Cliff given that and his disassociation
of late I wondered if he might be
thinking about taking the plunge and
ending his life there are a few promo
photos of him looking around where he
still has the beard and he just kind of
looks like he's not blending in with
anyone anymore then there are a couple
where he's shaving and it makes me
wonder what is he getting ready for
cleaning up for the Wilderness baby
burial I mean maybe but this mention of
Carl Havoc is pretty direct this is a
reference to a sketch on the comedy show
I think you should leave with Tim
Robinson in that he puts on a bunch of
Prosthetics and makeup to go out and
film himself bothering people at the
mall once he gets there it takes a turn
and after refusing to go through with
the bit he tells his producer I don't
even want to be around anymore that's
the part that's become a reaction image
so that makes it sound like Ben is in a
pretty bad spot and might need Misty to
talk him down where they're at also
complicates things since Kristen slash
Crystal's body should be right there
where she fell but that could also be
hidden due to the snowstorm I don't
think that's a given that he would
discover or see her there with all the
visions that are otherwise going nowhere
it has felt like Ben was on his way out
and I think there's at least a 50 50
chance of him not making out of this
season weirdly there's one detail out
there that makes me think he could
survive one of the big shots from the
season 2 trailer we're yet to see is the
one where they're carrying the body on a
stick based on the shoes that we can see
we can say for sure that that's not
Crystal and the fact that there are two
of them would also rule Ben out I said
at the end of my episode 6 video that I
think losing the baby sets up a dark
turn for the team because they don't
have the expectation of his birth of his
coming that was something that brought
them together as a group I think it
would be natural for things to go off
the rails but adding been to the body
count on top of whoever is on the stick
might be Overkill I do still think that
things will get dark though which is why
some of these promo photos are
surprising at first glance there are
several shots of them outside the cabin
where people look to be doing okay
they're shots of Ty and Van being in
love and even one where Mari has a big
smile on her face it gives the sense
that even though this terrible tragedy
happened people are essentially moving
on in their own ways and I think that
probably has something to do with what
we see happen with Shauna in all of
these Clips the teaser trailer opens
with a voiceover where you hear Lottie
say I know there's a lot of pain right
now but let it out we see that she has a
bloody nose as she's saying that and
that seems to be connected to this
episode 7 clip that was released by MTV
in that we see Shauna first go after
Misty who's humming and that sets her
off for some reason she goes after her
and punches her in the face and starts
screaming that she killed her baby not
steps between them to defend her first
then Shauna starts talking about her
dream and them being covered in blood
and you see Ty scream at her to stop
because she's acting insane van tries to
hold on to her and calm her down and
Shauna bites her hand and breaks free so
that Lottie has to step in between and
after a stare down Shauna punches her in
the nose which is where that blood came
from so it looks like after taking that
shot she stands back up and tells her to
let the pain out and apparently she does
that there were hints of this in other
trailers so Shauna going off is
something I've been expecting to see but
this still looks kind of wild because it
makes it look like she's just handing
them out and like raining down punches I
guess the show has moved into the
territory where it's not a gibbon that
what we see in trailers is real but I'm
guessing this actually happens
considering shawna's loss and the
situation they're in not being conducive
to being able to work her way through it
in any sort of healthy way it's pretty
much the opposite of that so A violent
Outburst isn't hard to imagine and this
Twist of Lottie taking a shot and then
essentially asking for more is
interesting given the tensions that
exist between them it also makes me
think back to the vision that Lottie had
when Travis died in that there was a
quick flash of a bloody face and the
most popular theory is that it was
lottie's face it's covered in blood it's
so beat up it's hard to say for sure
that it is her and it could certainly be
the aftermath of this beating that
Shauna is delivering here because in
both the trailer and the clip we see
that she is throwing her hands around to
say the least after that there's another
shot of adult Lottie with her therapist
saying this is what it wants for us to
be together there's a shot of them
sitting on the floor in a circle then
shots of them dancing around the fire
outside and one of them taking shots of
what looks like tequila in fact in all
of these shots alcohol features
prominently the dancing certainly makes
it look like there are a lot of strong
feelings involved in the reunion but
mostly warm ones as opposed to the anger
and paranoia in the cabin coming from
Shauna not ask who wants to get started
and adult Shauna who has a bottle in her
hand says to be honest I've already
gotten started then Nat tells someone
that she thinks it might be time to stop
resisting and I think she's probably
talking to Lottie because she is isn't
in all these inside shots but you do see
her in most of them also while she's
saying that there are a couple of shots
of her by herself where she looks
distressed with a shot of the antler
Queen sitting in her psychiatrist's
office considering this is a trailer and
the way it's cut could be misleading I
can't say for sure but this could
confirm that those therapy sessions are
so weird because they're just not real
the theory that they only take place in
her head is starting to look pretty good
one thing about all of these shots of
the adults having a great time together
seeing them carry on and just having a
fine time is that I know what kind of
show I'm watching and that gives me
concern about what will happen next I
feel like this state of bliss is not
something that they'll be able to hold
on to for very long and wonder what the
thing that will come along to knock them
back down will be after all Shauna is
under investigation and for good reason
she did murder someone and they all help
to destroy the body even though it
hasn't been mentioned lately Missy also
murdered Jessica who worked for Tai who
left her son while her wife's in the
hospital because of a wreck she was
responsible for and then you have van
who is either not planning for the
future and losing her business because
she strung out on pills or maybe she has
the terminal illness that she said that
her mother had that she hasn't mentioned
to anyone or both and and Lottie and Nat
are both having visions of the antler
Queen which is all to say I guess they
should live it up while they can there
are just a couple of unconnected shots
in the trailer and then I'll wrap this
up there's one of them where they're in
a circle from below and there are photos
that look like they're connected to this
in the circle Lottie looks like she's
really trying hard to connect to the
Wilderness energy so if I had to guess I
would say this might be a little
ceremony before the ceremony for the
funeral where the they could be a little
bit more Wilderness God friendly there's
a shot of adult tie and bands sitting
together where it looks like she's
moving in for a kiss and then one of
Shauna crying out which is probably
during the burial I think that's
probably a good place to leave things
like this shot of adult Shauna holding a
goat there's a lot that makes you think
here there's a lot to think about and
there's only three episodes left so I
think things are gonna get crazy let me
know what you think in the comments
please like this video If you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon